welcome everybody to my talk honey i
shrunk the target variable so before i
start quick question who actually gets
the reference to the movie
anyone said oh okay so i wasn't too bad
in choosing this
yeah so what inspired me to give this
talk is
that working as a data scientist you
surely know that you're kind of feature
engineering a lot of your time you're
coming up with cool transformation
combining features
and sometimes it doesn't stop with the
features sometimes you also think about
transforming the target variable right
and this is an area where there are a
lot of pitfalls and when i began my
journey as a data scientist i stepped in
some of those pitfalls
and this is why i want to share this
point with you
so
just a small introduction of myself so
i'm head of data science at innovex
i have a mathematical background really
care about mathematical modeling
bringing stuff into production
did a few projects in personalization
and recommender system of course i'm a
huge fan of python the pi data stack and
also contributed to some open source
projects like pi scaffold for instance
and i work at innovex we are an i.t
project house with a focus on digital
transformation yeah and basically offer
everything from app development ui ux
itunes operation and of course also the
data part like data engineering data
science and this is the part where i
work in
but coming to the talk and i want to
start with a small little recap about
metrics
so
when we have any kind of regression
problem right we have to decide for
some metric that tells of us if it's
good or bad whatever we're gonna fit in
the end and there are several metrics
but in most cases people actually rely
on the root mean squared error right
it's like the most often used
metric for regressions in practice
in fact it's uh like a default criterion
in psychic learn and some just use them
as a default and one thing i want to
tackle in this in this talk
is to answer the question if it really
makes sense in every use case
and um also how to decide if something
makes sense or not the root the root
mean squared error or if one should
rather
choose another metric
so we'll actually deal with four
different metrics so this is why i want
to give a small repetition so what we
see here on the upper left is the root
mean squared error yeah you see the the
target y and y hat our prediction our
estimation and um as you know then it's
squared and we take the square root
and this is like the the quadratic way
of judging the the difference you can
also do it in a
in an absolute way this is where we have
the mean absolute error
usually know those two
really well
and for cases for use cases where we are
rather interested in some
relational errors so to say where we
care about
how much we deviate from some given
target percentage percentage-wise there
are in the lower row the root mean
squared percentage error where we just
divide by the the target
and then there's a squared version of
this and also an absolute version the
mean absolute percentage error
shown here on the right and we're going
to use those
throughout the talk
so now
coming to our actual use case so imagine
i had a beautiful car like this but gas
prices are really high so i want to sell
this car
and in fact nowadays people would maybe
ask me the first question if the tank is
actually full or empty but just assume
that i want to sell this car and i have
no clue about cars and um so i asked
myself what kind of price should i ask
for yesterday we had a nice session of
mobility of course i could use their
platform but let's say i want to come up
with something myself
i could
come to the idea of fitting a model
on a database with a lot of car features
and
the the prices where those cars were
sold so like a database
similar to the one you have at mobile or
car guru or whatever
and
what we're going to use now is the
database the so-called used car database
with kaggle as i said we have a lot of
different features like regal type model
registration date and so on and then we
use this metal to estimate the price
based on those features we're going to
treat this
as a kind of fair market value and then
if i'm a good
seller i could say i go a little bit
below this fair price or if i'm rather
greedy i could be a little bit above
and let's set this as our as our use
case and so far we haven't really talked
of
about the metric
so
to get closer now to this question what
metric would actually make sense let's
start with two questions so assume i had
10 of those cars and assume that i could
get
50 000 for each and one of them this
would be like the like let's say a fair
price but i'm kind of lazy so the first
option would be i sell nine cars for
fifty thousand by the last cars for
forty thousand or the second option
would be what if i just rather sell all
10
by with the price of 49 000 right so
what kind of difference would this make
i mean in the end i'm kind of losing 10
000 euro but if you look at those two
options using the root mean squared
error then option one would be much
worse because you have this one outlier
of kind of for difference of ten
thousand and this is a squared so
asking yourself this question you might
rather go for an absolute difference
right because in the end we think in a
currency we think in euro and we don't
think in square euro we we think in in
euro
so this is why the root been spread
error maybe is not the best idea but
then second question so what if i get 10
i get 1 000 euro less
assuming that the actual car value is
100 000 or 10 000 right i would in the
first case
give
a discount of one percent
and in the second case of 10
and i mean the way we are bargaining
like going 10 down is a lot more than
one percent
so if we look at this question
from the perspective of our different
metrics we might say that yeah well for
the root mean squared error or mean
absolute error this makes no difference
because it's in the end the difference
is 1000 but
percentage-wise it makes a lot of
a lot of difference and so this is why
for this use case for our use case
a good metric would maybe be the mean
absolute percentage error and i think
it's important to ask you those kinds of
questions if you would use different
metrics if you do a regression if you
have a regression use case at hand
because this is how in the end your
users will um see
your your data product
but
yeah this is already the first uh the
key learning that
the right metric really depends on your
use case and of course it will also
affect your results so depending on what
metric you're going to choose your model
will come up with other numbers so it's
important to ask you questions like this
whenever
you are dealing with some use case
now imagine that we actually go for the
root mean squared error because yeah
it's the default
in in many of the psychic learns
estimators
and what does it actually mean the root
mean squared error
and this is going to be the only mathy
slide here
i couldn't let it go
so
what what happens if we take the the the
root mean squared error here without the
root so that it makes no sense or makes
no difference in this case if we express
this continuously as a continuous random
variable our target so assuming we keep
the features fixed and assuming we have
a whole density then the sum becomes an
integral we have to include the density
over our targets
and if we want to now minimize this it's
like what we always do we
derive set it to zero and in the end
we end up having y hat
is the integral over y times the density
and this is actually the definition of
the expectation value right so the x the
definition of the mean and this is
really interesting because so whenever
you're minimizing um for the root mean
squared or error or just the mean
squared error you're actually trying to
estimate the mean of your residual
distribution
and this is really important thing to to
keep in mind and will come up also later
there is an analog proof for the mean
absolute error in this case
you are looking for the meteon and this
is
really important to keep in mind
when you're
choosing a metric so for the math
skeptics i mean there's some out there
you
can also try this out so
the root mean squared error and let's
say we take the price as y
and just use this on this kaggle data so
we
um we just take the the our whole um
[Music]
our whole prices and we use psychic
scipy to optimize
and we see that it's actually close to
some rounding error to the mean
and the same goes for the mean absolute
[Music]
mean absolute error
and um the median
so this isn't the this is the case so
far we haven't done anything to target
variable right we haven't transformed it
in any way
but
these
values will come up also later
so second key learning here is now
that
as we said the mean so the expected
value minimizes the root mean squared
error and the median minimizes the mean
absolute error
so now to the actual topic of the talk
now what happens if we start playing
around with a lock
if we start shrinking the prices because
if we look at the distribution of prices
in our use case
well this looks like a log normal
distribution and even if you if you fit
the log normal distribution to the value
you see it's not really perfect
especially here
um
this will be important later but you
might come to the idea well
there may be outliers and it looks a bit
skewed so why not just use the logarithm
and
or apply the logarithm and the data will
look better
so
let's just try this and see what happens
so what we're going to do we take the
log of the price
as our new target variable we're going
to minimize
using the root mean squared error again
so this is you can think of this like a
model with only an intercept in a way so
far we haven't used any features
and then we transform the whole thing
back so let's just
do this
as before so this time we take the log
you see here then we do the we we
optimize we minimize using the root mean
squared error we get 8.3 and then we
transform it back right and we end up
having
around forty thousand so for comparison
the numbers we had before
the mean
was actually
um
six thousand eight hundred so we are
completely off we are rather really
close to the median and this is
at least when i thought it was the first
time was to my surprise um really like
the media and so okay i transformed i
minimized i transformed back and now i'm
having like optimized another metric it
was like i would have optimized for the
mean absolute error
and
so
this really got me questioning so okay
what happened here and then
when you now do the math and actually
calculate what happens like
transforming and minimizing transforming
back at least for log normal residual
distribution you can easily prove and
you find all this also in the blog post
to this talk that taking the logarithm
minimizing for the root men's squared
error and transforming back will lead to
the median so if we were really
interested in the mean
then we would have to correct this by
adding one half sigma square and we can
also try this out for our data which is
not perfectly log normal
and
there sigma square
so the variance in this case of the
residual distribution if we add this to
our
to our estimation y hat and apply the
exponential function
then we are a little bit higher than the
the actual mean but
this is
due to the fact that it was not lock
normal but we see that we are much
closer and that we have kind of
corrected this
and of course you can ask now for every
of those metrics what happens if i do
this like transform minimize transform
back and
um if i'm actually interested in another
metric like the
um mean absolute percentage error or the
root mean squared percentage error
and in all those cases i have to apply
different corrections
given of course i'm always assuming a
log-normal residual
distribution that you don't always have
in practice so this is why this
difference has come
and
yeah so if you're interested in
all the math behind this it's um here
given on the
blog post
and
so the the third key learning that we
have now that we saw that transforming
your target
might actually
change what you're minimizing this is
really important to to keep in mind
that be careful
what you evaluate and what you train and
if you in between
um kind of transform your target
variable then this will in most cases
except of the mean absolute
error here the correction is zero
in this case it makes no difference but
for all the others you have to correct
so now can we use this actually to to
help us
can we
maybe gain something from this nice
insight
so what if for instance submetric is not
supported in our favorite machine
learning library and so assume that you
want to optimize for the root mean
squared percentage error
and it's not available but you only have
the root mean squared error this was for
instance in an uh the case in a nice
cackle contest six years ago
the question they asked was to somehow
predict the sales in rosmann stores and
the evaluation was in the end done with
the help of the root mean squared
percentage error and all people kind of
asked so okay
how do we do this now right because at
least psychic learn
i'm not sure if it's still the case
today but at that time
hasn't had this so you could not just
say i directly
want to optimize for the woodman square
percentage error
so
again
what
we could do instead of just fitting the
model and using the root mean squared
error as a loss and evaluating the
prediction with another
score
another metric like the root mean
squared percentage error we could
as we have just learned first take the
logarithm so transform it
then we fit the model using the root
mean squared percentage error
and then we choose the corresponding
correction
and go back
and this trick kind of helps us
then to have actually
minimized a metric that
our
machine learning library doesn't even
support
and
so the um
[Music]
so i i did this for for the use case
that i just showed
um this time i used all the features did
some random forest
on this features
and
checked what happens if i have the the
raw
the raw results and compare this with
the root mean squared the mean absolute
error and the map and the smpe
and compare this now percentage-wise to
the log transformation and doing the
correction
and this is what you see on on the
y-axis
so
let's just i think it gets easier to
understand if we just look at the first
column so assume i do the log
transformation
i fit with root mean squared error i
transform back and then i look at the
results using the root mean squared
error then
i i'm actually worse than if i had not
done this transformation i mean this is
uh
what we what we saw before that we would
actually need to do a correction
but since it's not perfectly look normal
we are even getting worse
and
so positive numbers uh mean a
deterioration and a negative percentage
number mean an improvement
so this tells us
that
if i'm if i would be really interested
in the root mean squared error doing any
kind of transformation is actually bad
right so we end up being worse
and then not doing any transformation
and if you wonder about the last row so
this is a fitted correction of course
you could instead of doing
the mathematically correct
correction
you could also use some holdout set to
to minimize this one parameter to get a
kind of a fitted correction this is why
the last row is always better
so now what happens with
if we were interested in the mean
absolute error in this case we see a
slight improvement this is also what we
have seen so
um what is also
also proven that if we um take the
logarithm if we go back then we actually
were looking then we actually arrive at
the median
and this is like optimizing the mean
absolute error so we see slight
improvements in this case the sigma 2
correction is also 0 as we've seen
before
and
using a fitted correction gets us a
little improvement where this becomes
interesting and maybe also
intuition-wise
interesting is if we look now at
percentage errors i mean this
is already the intuition right because
you um yeah going to lock space
kind of makes absolute absolute
relations um rather in relative
relations
so
just applying the
logarithm without any correction
improves us by almost eleven percent
using the correct back transformation
and correction it's a little bit better
and
fitting it gets us even two more
percentage points
um where it now really shines is if you
look at a metric like the root mean
squared percentage error like it was
asked in the cackle here
doing um the the no correction gets us
an improvement of 12 percent
using the mathematically correct one is
um 28
and even fitting gets us even more
and this was in the kaggle competition
like the key ingredient to
to win this competition so the um
the winner back then wrote a really nice
blog post about all the tricks he
applied and also showed how he
mathematically derived this
correction
what i showed before and
it was
like like i said one of the key
ingredients so you could not win it
without
using it
and this is what really intrigued me at
this case in this case that
in one way it's a pitfall you should be
always careful but if you know what
you're doing
then you can use it um
for your advantage and with this message
i want to actually
close this talk so please think before
you shrink
and
yeah if you want to know more so
as i said
there's a whole blog post with a lot
more information about this and you can
also
try out all the code i showed in in
jupiter notebooks and run it for
yourself
so thanks a lot for your time and your
attention and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you a lot willian uh super
insightful talk uh let's let's go to the
questions for the audience once again we
are in slido
uh what do you think about linear
transforms or other nonlinear ones like
box [ __ ] or etc
for the so for the linear ones so if a
fiend transformation you're pretty safe
so it's always
um it's always difficult um when you're
using non-linear transformation then you
run into trouble that those things apply
for affine ones like the one
you always do a deep learning that
you're normalizing and whatever and
standardization there you actually don't
fall into this trap so it's basically
most of the time the the locker rating
and with box [ __ ] i would also assume
that you have to be really careful then
because you're
really transforming a lot so but i
haven't done the math on this but
pretty sure that you have to be careful
all right next one um
what is your opinion or experience on
capturing skewness by modeling a log
normal distribution explicitly
for example by maximizing
the log likelihood
so
um
[Music]
i
we did this a few times especially so
log normal distribution is quite often
you use it if you have some kind of
sales
value for instance there you can use it
[Music]
the problem always are the the the
outlier and um
i mean
the question is again the use case so
what
what is it that i'm really interested in
so if i have a log normal distribution i
would maybe argue from the beginning
that i am more interested in getting the
median of the residual risk
distribution and then i would apply the
the local rhythm to
eventually minimize the mean absolute
error again due to the fact that
maybe the use case is like this that
you're
[Music]
that you're
trying to optimize
the number of some some goods that you
need to predict for optimal demand
planning and you don't want to throw
something away and then
quadratic
um difference just makes no sense in
many use cases but yeah i would say it
really depends on the use cases
and if you um
yeah if
if the use cases use case needs it then
the log normal distribution is fine so
for a lot of bayesian
models
i also used it so
yeah
all right let's go to the next one how
do you compute
mape
how do you deal with exactly zero values
that's a good question yeah um with
exactly
so if the target is exactly zero of
course then you would
divide by zero which is uh
problematic
i mean sometimes you can
argue that you have a certain offset
but um that you can just apply that you
add uh some some of your offset to your
well to your target to avoid this
but
again this also depends on the use case
if you are if this is allowed or if this
if you run into an an error but yeah
percentage wise
of course um yeah it's
makes no makes no sense so you have to
be really careful if
you maybe have some zero inflated stuff
with the mean absolute percentage error
but yeah offset i would first try to
think of an offset or
find out if
the metric makes sense in this use case
if we're dealing a lot with this
next one how do you combine strong
skewness with zero inflated distribution
as log becomes then impossible
again zero skewness
with zero inflated
yes how do you combine strong skewness
with zero inflated distribution
yeah there it's a
tricky question
i would have to to
look
also up um
[Music]
how to how to do this so not i cannot
really answer um directly i mean
depending on
the use case you could also
maybe
[Music]
yeah
find out i mean zero zero inflated uh
distributions
is a
really complex
topic to to model itself and then if
again you have maybe a lot of outliers
um
yeah
i would have to look this up myself
actually
let's go to the next one we have two
minutes left and three questions
how would you decide whether or not to
transform your target variable
nonlinear transform will change the data
itself while linear ones
just might help
opt
does it just might help
help opt
that that's unclear for me as well
so the last sentence is non-linear
transform will change the data itself
while linear ones
just might help opt
maybe to opt out
okay let's move on to the next one
who who asked the question can reach out
to the speaker afterwards is the person
here maybe then
no help
help out okay
yeah maybe some is a
typo
but let's move to the next one and then
we can clarify
uh
log x plus one
or how do you deal with log0
yeah this was
again
like similar to the percentage-wise so
if you have uh
zero data in then uh you cannot divide
by by zero and yeah this uh log one uh x
plus 1 is quite often
used and also
available in most
yeah arithmetic libraries as an extra
function but then you also have to ask
yourself
how am i changing what i wanna um
what i wanna achieve in the end so
yeah
i can only say that this is an option
depends on the use case as always
yes so let's go to the last one uh in
one hour last minute uh the correction
makes the
msc worse right
yeah i think not sure if you already
answered that as well
or if it makes us
yeah
i under i think this was what
here yeah
i mean this
kind of when i first saw these numbers
it also surprised me because
in this case you would assume to see
like zero right because we just
mathematically proved that it's um
that you should end up with the mean
again but the thing is that uh
at the beginning we saw
that the distribution
i mean it's
it looks quite like normal but it's far
from being perfectly log normal and this
was
the the distribution over the whole data
so this is only a residual distribution
if we take a model with only an
intercept but
the actual results i showed
were
was a model
where i used all the features and then
i have no blood of the residual
distributions but
also in this case it was not perfectly
log normal
and this explains
why it was uh
was worse so
you cannot really assume
that you have a log normal
residual distribution so the main
takeaway here is if you really want to
have the root mean squared error in the
end then don't do
some kind of log transformation
all right we are out of time so
direct your questions directly to the
speaker afterwards and
let's
give a last round of applause for
willian thank you a lot
[Applause]